Xavier roads here in the Rich Eisen show
how you been Savior I appreciate that
so tell me everything you just heard in
that meeting last every single word can
you cough it up oh no no no all right
yeah
when when did when were you able to turn
the page from what happened on Sunday to
what you need to do this Sunday Xavier
when did that happen so Tuesday local
clay lived in a moment for Sunday night
Monday Oh My Damn dude they had to get
ready where were you when that play took
place I was on the fine line right and
so were you looking were you one of
those guys with your yeah everybody
ready to see what's gonna happen
once it happened you know it was all she
wrote you could tell the tale about how
reacted to her you could say I was a
great light I'm spirit so the emotion
emotion emotion about to play a lot of
people some time apart that we're gonna
lose because you know it was since I can
play it was a miracle you know it was a
miracle Cagney would throw and yeah I
mean we end up coming up on top yeah and
and Savior Rhodes joining me here look
you've been a rookie in this league and
you know what it takes to be a rookie in
this league and you know how well some
of the Saints rookies have played this
year at defensive back what do you think
Marcus Williams was thinking on that
play best you can tell as being a clue I
mean I don't know he probably trying to
make you talk like this but I don't know
I mean I'm not him and I've been in that
situation before on this big you know
you just try to make tackle but anyway
you know sometimes you can't make
everything but you came that one clay
define you as a player or or the
person's you know me you have a long
career heading you have many more
opportunities to make
I mean you're gonna get beat sometimes
you're gonna mess up sometimes then it
is all about how you bounce back from
that mistake yeah you know he I mean
every it was a big place he minutes and
everything but he did help this team
come back with the interception
um detect change the momentum of the
game you know so he did a lot that game
actually helped the team but I gotta say
I mean no one's perfect
no one's perfect in football to the
point where you you can have a perfect
game you can't name one person who had a
perfect game
in the game of football so I mean yeah
happen so what's it like walking around
that town right now Xavier your team is
as close to being the first ever home
team to play in its home building in the
history of the great game of the Super
Bowl what is it like walking around that
town right now um honestly I haven't
been up but I'm guessing it's probably
like refine the fans are probably happy
a prior excited about opportunities we
have ahead of us to make history here in
the locker personally and we're happy
but we're more focused on trying to get
it's a failure you know I'm trying to
get the victory we're not really trying
to look passionately because you don't
want anything bad to happen we just
trying to focus on the guy and once
Sunday's is over you know all right like
10 o'clock when every time the game is
over
you know then that's when we feel like
we can celebrate and say we go now
whatever so what what challenges does
Philadelphia present what have you seen
on film and what can you tell us if we
honor they have a great defense great on
defense
I'm not a defense but I'm watching their
games
you know they people is pretty good it'd
be nice being linebackers and my
concerns and a corners of an aggressive
foot in the covered space and all
friends that past couple of weeks
I think you know a key on you know Falls
is trying to get photos in the groove
and things trying to get them
comfortable to the point where you can
make make great throws and they
get us get the confidence from the
receivers players but I believe he sees
a keeper playing good enough to have a
clean win and if he wasn't he won't be
in this exhibition we're there now
Xavier Rhodes joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show and in that defensive
locker room when the quarterback
conversation comes up as to who should
have been throughout the entire year
what's that been like for you guys you
have no control over it but obviously
you need some points being put on the
board for you to protect so what has
been what has been the conversations
that you guys have had while keenum
started his ascension this year no
conversation at all has always been next
man up I mean this is football
I mean ever we have haven't sat down to
have a conversation
I mean Sam should we start or Teddy's no
next man up simple dust again and so
when it all comes down to it when you're
out there on the field on Sunday night
what will you be thinking at any moment
will you pause at a moment just say you
know what I'm this is this is what I've
been playing for a right to go to the
Super Bowl this is what I dreamt about
when I grew up in Florida no I mean to
the point no you stay here you want an
afford to this they're practicing at
this moment put on game day you can't
being all moment you came to see him
though I'm here you know I'm here and I
see championship you got a great more
focus on that man sitting there planning
that game and kind of want to get to the
school board rather than being you know
surprised and all into your feelings and
something like that to the point where
you like oh you know going to the moment
in in Annecy chemistry okay not worried
about planning in decisions and and how
much of the contact if you had with
prime D on throughout your your career
and then playing career not much but you
know more like he's a busy guy and I'm a
busy guys call derivitive probably get
some contact late on mohkumat this year
well you know he would always tell me
our knees always told me
being a Florida boy himself that you
know from Fort Myers that he always had
a choice of where he got to play and he
says notice I never when I was a free
agent chose a cold-weather spot how cold
is it for somebody growing up from the
Sunshine State up there in the Upper
Midwest Xavier no it's pretty cold cold
is it in Florida in Miami in 60 oh I
should tell you right so how many layers
what are you laid you dude just really
good you start to tolerated me not a
year so you tolerate the weather no okay
you get yourself mentally ready for it
and you all really think about it
anymore I'm anything but in your first
year you in a rush to get back home to
the to the Sunshine State or wherever
you from but sure after your first year
you know you just don't tolerate and you
sit down I you know what's coming so
let's just keep this up prepare mentally
for now I'm just looking for some advice
because I'm coming regardless we're
coming for a whole like eight days
Savior I mean yeah I mean you gotta just
think of somewhere Hawaii or something
okay
my old pro days think of my old Pro Bowl
days well listen congrats on making the
Pro Bowl and I say this with all
heartfelt sincerity I hope you don't
play in it for your sake yeah yeah okay
Xavier you take care thanks for calling
in just a few days you got that save
your rose so Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience